خطوه وبيان تاريخي من بكين بالاعلان عن
توافق سعودي ايراني على استئناف العلاقات
بين البلدين بعد سبع سنوات من القطيعه خطا
اول خطواته في العاشر من مارس الماضي
ثلاثها خطوات متسارعه عبر اتصالات متبادله
بين وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان ونظيره الايراني الامير حسين عبد
الله تمهيدا طبعا لاول لقاء بينهما في
السادس من ابريل الجاري كانت العاصمه
الصينيه في الواجهه مجددا بعد استضافتها
لقاء بين وزير الخارجيه السعوديه ونظيره
الايراني نتج عنه طبعا بيان مشترك شمل بحث
استئناف الرحلات الجويه وتسهيل منح
التاشيرات وكذلك بدء ترتيبات اعاده فتح
السفرتين والقنصليات بين البلدين اما في
الثامن من شهر ابريل الجاري زار فريق فني
سعودي العاصمه الايرانيه طهران بحث هذا
الفريق اليات اعاده فتح السفاره السعوديه
في طهران والقنصليه في مشهد في خطوه اخرى
نحو تنفيذ بن ود الاتفاق الثلاثي الذي وصف
بالمفاجئ والتاريخي قبل ان تشهد امس
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض زياره وفد من
طهران لاتخاذ التدريبات الترتيبات طبعا
اللازمه لفتح سفاره ايران في الرياض
وقنصلياتها اضافه الى بحث استئناف نشاط
الممثليه الايرانيه الدائمه في منظمه
التعاون الاسلاميه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات